invitiamo la realtà va scoraggiato
ciao ragazzi tornati a una puntata di
questo format che ancora non ha un nome
oggi stiamo per fare una cosa che
pensavo impossibile da un po di anni
ormai sono due anni io non con tutto il
sapone
nel senso che tutto il sapone che io in
casa non lo dicevo da un po di anni il
sapone non regala traffic e io non ho
mai capito come lui riesca a creare
questi saponi buoni e soprattutto per i
perché per me è tutto quello che
compreso per mercato il più delle volte
impossibile da fare a casa oggi anche
grazie a raffaele che per chi non
conoscesse ha voluto essere un mio amico
giorno muscolare ma anche una linea di
prodotti raffaele ruberto skin noi
creeremo un sapone fatto in casa che lui
ha assicurato essere fatto per perdersi
è naturale spartiamo notare nei vasi che
lo so dare un mercato ma un complimento
106 di sanremo se la frana regalo per te
perché sei diventato proprio pure dei
miei alchimisti forse l'archivista più
bravo che ho mai formato semmai vorrei
interrompermi per continuare a farmi i
complimenti attive poi ladro erano
faccio complimenti così faccio i
complimenti perché sei veramente bravo
perfetto come se il naso lui c'ha un
naso di scendere fino a roma tanti io
sono più
così tanto una puzza dei miei fratelli
che quindi appena sento qualcosa che non
sa di stalla piacere lasciamo di link
qua sotto qualora voleste proprio
prendervi tutta quanta lista di
ingredienti è molto facile 3 ingrediente
tu hai creato proprio quello più
semplice per tutti giusta esatto io ho
trovato un fornitore che vede queste
cose che un detergente queste ne intendi
bravissimo cristallo trasparente si
chiama priva di sls sulfate se fanno
proprio la schiuma però invitano
mammella o caio molto delicato perché
modo delicato ma sempre krypton assieme
piani per questo quindi lo dovremmo pure
colorare a sé e profumare interforze c'è
quello facile nel senso di facile puoi
fare una bontà di queste fanno ottimi
legali pur vero che butta sarebbe
partenze puoi fare o anche sapone avremo
bisogno per quello che vogliamo fare
facciamo un chilo e abbiamo tutto enrico
quindi con due di questi ne facciamo
tutti lo riservo non è se non riusciamo
nei piedi e 500 e abbiamo selezionato
questa qui a diamante questo poiché
viene una piramide ne sono stati tanto
tempo a cercare di capire quale delle
due utilizzare e non voglio farle
entrambi facciamo un toblerone o
facciamo dei seni io propongo di fare
una richiesta online a far scegliere sia
la forma sia il colore è che il profilo
aromatico che mi segue su instagram
ragazzi sto girando insieme a raffaele
un video sui saponi noi meglio questa
che alla fine viene tipo dei segni o
delle piramidi che assomigliano a un
toblerone dio
[Musica]
fischi lo lasciamo un like perché le
maggiori
se anche voi amate le regioni e
surgelata
[Risate]
[Musica]
torniamo un attimo a fare il sapone
iniziamo subito a sciogliere laddove
cucina anche 1 e 2
seguiteci siamo in cucina vediamo è
iniziato a tagliarli giusto vederli
parente però cinesi in padella nella
pentola
sennò ce n'è troppo esatto qui i più
piccoli sono prima fate e sensuale e
comete ieri pur of life fare per noi
abbiamo scelto di usare la base di
sapone e invece di prepararlo ad hoc
diciamo numero faresti di base come
facevano i nonni dei nostri nonni che
prendiamo un olio e con la una cosa
molto caustico che si chiama lenitivi ha
quindi che i rischi e bruciati man e
quindi io lo faccio in laboratorio ma
non ti consiglio di farlo a casa ottimi
nerissimo guarda o magari cubetti di
ghiaccio
siamo più di fumo e di una soddisfazione
incredibile ma ci mette pochissimo ad
una fiamma molto bassa ovviamente lui
ama i dettagli guarda gli fanno bene
complimenti perché quando iniziamo con
guglielmo facciamo tutto il contrario
realtà quando faccio una cosa migliore
sono anarchico che a nardò io apprezzo
la sua irregolari ata non è perfetta
come scopriamo le cose basiano facciamo
delle cose non giuste come si dice
esattamente come detto al momento io
seguo raffaele perché raffaele sa cosa
fa voi non sapete niente a non sapere
aprirvi una scatoletta di tonno usa e
meno di noi
per favore io so di non sapere testa
scodella scrivete qua sotto e destra
scodella che poi ho usato
una scodella come linea guida non si
sbriga di aspettare questa vetta la
crisi serve perché il taglio appena si
scioglie tutto quanto ma veramente
pochissimi minuti torniamo al tavolo per
azione in giornate come queste tante
cattive energie non mi tocca eccoci qui
siamo tornati questo qui è il nostro
sapone bello caldo non toccato e quindi
noi faremo in due colori abbiamo deciso
quindi di fare una specie di vortice
fattura fissato prendere questi
contenitori che ha riscaldato in
modalità rifar sofisticare subito il
sapone il secondo quesito della vita
colore a casa oppure daltonico argento
prezzi argento non so se state capendo e
viola ha proposto che nel coro athena
set chiuso e poi parlo lo zucchero per
murray che chiusa
dicevi scusami oro e nero seconda
domanda che brutta faccio questa per il
giro argento e viola e oro
mamma mia e nero
i cosmetici e humphrey ciò che ci hanno
le piccole e micro particelle di
plastica che vanno poi nell'acqua e
questi sono da micro particelle di
plastica sono mica naturale quindi
metalli naturali i minerali click a
colonica raggi mentali che non andiamo
di mine mettere plastica negli oceani
bombay back to basic software motore che
tu sei il problema sia privato l'unico
che ha vinto la lotteria e fa il e
raffaele a tipo 270 odori c'è proprio
sparami n'è uno strano parliamo del
leeds ea cuba è una maledizione del
sardo io ho un gusto che mi piace tanto
e thun e un altro primato però sempre a
roma terapeutico così gen
parma 3 parti coltano materno maran
terapeutica a roma terapeutico a nuova
terra per il tecnico inglese americano
comunque li racchiude
ma non è certo una roma diciamo che mi
fa ricordare tanto il ciambellone miglia
e il bergamotto
io ho scelto cosa mi fa ricordare una
delle merendine preferite che la festa
non ti manda cioccolato e arancio rosso
ed a sentire il nice
cacchio arancia cioccolato lancia
cioccolato questo è pazzesco
non provo più interessato mamma mia che
cos'è il tuo interessare ti do the scene
come questa beta
ultimo momento che quello del xix e del
profilattico approfitta dicevo del
profilo aromatico aperto così scelto poi
certo la vendita e il bergamotto tipo
ciambella io tipo di è sta sotto lato e
rancio rosso con le mettiamo il
sondaggio dei colori ma ha fatto vincere
l'accoppiata sono vicinissime il 51 per
cento
a vincere è stata l'accoppiata argento
in viola
iniziamo con l'argento perché questo
diventa una maggior palco primo prodotto
finale un cucchiaio di questo è un'amica
non quello non particelle nanoparticelle
micro tasse gelli che su di plastica
questi sono miche naturali ok quindi un
cucchiaio di mika in uno questo qua è un
altro cucchiaio per cento un collo
radicale perfetto vivo questo
dibattimento la crisi presentata
profumazione informazione ha stravinto
uno dei due sta andando a vedere
ad aver vinto channel da una
profumazione sarà vaniglia e bergamotto
voglio fare 15 millilitri e 15.000 litri
quando un bel odore è bello d'ora poi
diminuirlo a 10 10 19 guglielmo di
fallire pure atleta e risolti mettere
direttamente un pochettino dello strike
altra benevolo essenziale certo non sono
chimici non c'è un sondino lab si inizia
con l'accoppiata sono contento che abbia
l'inter sarà in non è pensioni vignoso
bravissimo vincere se conto che il mio
naso riusciva ad associare il dottore
per adesso si sa di aver dato un naso ci
si venga ordinato un credo per tu con
quelli perché ti senti capalle puzze
cene di resca riconoscersi biennio q mai
mischiare ragazzi quando sente di oli
essenziali la pipetta ovviamente tra i
due boccette perché scade di
compromettere la roma se promosso la
faccio un pochino alla vecchia maniera e
libertà fino a qui faccio 11 11 e molto
precisi ma veramente preciso raga mi
sento una classe tipo di hogwarts
emozioni che hai che mi ricordi
gli allievi viola che fa esplodere le
cose si sa che mi ricordi in neri
paciock che permette il preside ma tu
sai che mi ricordo marketing guardiamo
il dissenso è rivolta il soffitto che
forma daremo tra tette e toblerone
venetian questo possono essere dette
effettivamente mettiamoli su questo
esatto la folla deve rimanere fermo che
ha attraversato tre quarti di questo è
quello che devi capire ma se penso alla
velocità con cui abbiamo fatto un regalo
pazzesco pensare al nostro viaggio è un
regalo a qualcuno ok in cui abbiamo già
questo sopra piano piano piano e quindi
rovesciarlo
adesso si chiude la lista è un bene ci
dicono di fedelissimo venissimo
bellissimo alcol puro bravissimo per
togliere le bolle ruolo delle bolle c'è
un altro pochino facciamo triangolo
insieme tu puoi fare quello che vuoi la
creatività è tutto vostro
qua c'è questo qui è una delle cose più
ricche del mondo
io lo so però anche l'ammontare
all'ultimo lamiere messo a me ha
chiamato il miglio raccomandate la marca
invidioso forse si è geloso sta
rosicando quanto tempo per essere sicuri
al queen's e io direi un ora uno ora per
essere sicuri poi puoi trovare della
forma bar già mezz'ora sono già in
provincia dall'essere ci sono i
polpastrelli qualcuno toccato alcuno ha
toccato sente spago a spiegare un
football bull è arrivato il momento
della verità
chi vuole due temi no una volta si tinga
tinga la posso
[Applauso]
bello
l'animazione stupenda di è come regali
sono pazzeschi 4 lanka per i regali
oggi se il promosso un'altra votami sito
internet smalto rosa si è mosso per
cento cioè io volevo solamente
rispondere in un attimo una cosa sono
stato promosso a questo punto da allievo
a apprendista alchimista esatto tu se
sono mosso da inutile da eliminare
sapete anche che raffi e all'intera
solenne al instagram vi lasciamo tutto
quanto posso lo faccio apparire ovunque
da un sacco di consigli oltre che parla
dei suoi prodotti però ogni tanto li
potete chiedere 2000 cose vanno al di là
semplicemente vi facciamo vedere
quest'anno ancora più interessante
complesse mi raccomando se vi farete
toccateci su instagram facendoci vedere
che cosa avete creato e soprattutto
fateci sapere che a questi due secondo
cui dice ci vediamo domenica alle 12 con
una puntata in cucina buttata
ciao